oh my god the people are a lot smarter
than me have thought about um i don't i
don't think like what do you mean by
free will I guess is the question is
randomness is not free well I'm not a
duelist although we all are
instinctively from childhood duelists we
think there's a little man in our head
and that are a little woman in my case
you know and that person is acting and
choosing and if there's not really a
little person in your head then you
don't have free will but how can that be
that doesn't make any sense to me either
so I think you just kind of however
whatever i'm not a philosopher and as i
say people are much smarter than I am
have dealt with this but the way I think
about it is you just you know it may be
your biology is telling you to do these
things or whatever but you you act as if
you had free will and then the really
interesting question is then when do you
come to modify the biochemical processes
that direct your behavior and I have
both sort of professional interest in
this question and also a personal
interest because I have suffered from
depression I to meet and and I've had it
I had a happy childhood I have no dramas
of my life you know if we if we were
back in the days where we understood a
depression in some Freudian way there
would be nothing I couldn't I couldn't
account for it why should I have this
depression it's like the flu I would be
perfectly fine one day and then terribly
terribly depressed the next day and I do
take not so much anymore but not so much
does it anymore but i have taken prozac
and it helps and it makes me what I
think of as the normal me sort of like
you know claritin-d cures your allergies
it's the same to me I experienced it in
the same way as I would experience any
other kind of medication but that does
race people love to think about these
issues well it's the real Virginia the
despairing depressed for juniors that
the happy-go-lucky Virginia most people
who know me would say it's the sort of
cheerful 10 and actually people tend to
be surprised that I've been depressed
but it's that's an interesting question
of like who is the real you and and when
we're in an era where you can sort of
modify the real you I would argue that
the choice to modify or not is a sort of
self-fashioning choice you're deciding
what kind of person you want to be and
who is the you it's very deep far too
deep for me